today we're talking about threat
detection the growing tall virtual
machine family and chrome os flex i'm
christopher and welcome to this week in
clouds where we serve you the lowest
latency news
as your organization transition from art
teams to hybrid clouds or pure clouds
how you think about threat detection
must evolve as well especially when
confronting threat across many cloud
environments a new foundational
framework for thinking about threat
detection and public cloud computing is
needed to better secure digital
transformation because this term has
different meanings over time here's what
we meant by threat detection and
detection and responses a balanced
security strategies cover all three
elements of a security triad prevention
detection and responses vital changes
impact the transition from the
traditional environment to the clouds
and affect three key areas
threat landscape
it environment and detection methods
check out further detail from our cyber
security action team on the block
last year we added tall virtual machine
to compute engine offering a new family
a virtual machine optimized for
cost-effective performance for scale our
workload and now we at 302 announced the
reviews release of our first virtual
machine families based on the armed
architecture
tall t2a known for delivering excellent
performance for watch efficiency arm
bait shifts are already in mobile
devices and now have proven themselves
for super computing workloads
google cloud customer and developer now
have the option for choosing arm-based
google cloud virtual machine to test
develop and run their workload on the
optimal architecture for their workload
head to the blog to learn more about
this review
chrome os flex the cloud first easiest
to manage and fast operating system for
pcs and macs and now ready for your
fleet
software bloat clunky hardware and
security vulnerabilities can cause
unwanted damage
thankfully chrome os flag is just to fix
your legacy device's need and thanks to
everyone who has participated in our
early access program we have been able
to significantly improve the products in
many areas while certifying devices to
run chrome os flex you can now
experience modern computing at scale
that is better for your business with 19
less power consumption
if you want to read more about this
announcement or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we will see you
in the clouds
you